a hunter-gatherer's guide to the 21st
century this is
our book uh that we've been talking
about writing for well over a decade i
remember being in a comparative
anatomy lab with students back in like
2010
talking about our ideas for this book
and it's finally come to fruition we're
super excited about it
we encourage you to uh to look at the
site
and to consider pre-ordering we at the
moment
um there's there's people have been
asking about getting signed copies and
there's not a way for us to interact
with the publisher such that we can
actually sign copies and get them to
people
um but two things uh we're likely to put
up a
button here soon that any time
that you have pre-ordered you would be
able to go in and
enter your information and get a signed
book plate which is not the same
but we're also hoping to do some live
events in the fall
uh and there will also be uh more
information about that coming
coming soon but at live events uh if
they happen you know we will be trying
to
do some in places where there's actual
interest and if you showed up to that
there will be book signings as part of
that
we would far prefer to sign actual books
it seems the right way to us as well but
if you think about the logistical
problem of getting the books to the pen
and then to you
it becomes well that's actually that
it's it's not the books to the pen and
the books to you it's the it's the uh
is the contractual agreement with the
with the publisher oh there's an
additional layer that i uh
yeah yeah no the the physical stuff i i
got that
figured but it's the it's the
contractual stuff we would need another
another structure or something but yeah
so i will say also on the point on the
uh
from the point of view of looking at the
website uh probably most of you will
encounter things on your phones because
that's what's done but you should go see
if you can't dig
up a a laptop somewhere to look at the
site
from the uh the desktop because um
all of you have been begging for a
parallax scroll you will only
it's not a parallax scroll there's a
parallax scroll
you know so let's not go here that it
didn't end up being what happened
so um it sure looks like it's an
animation rather than a parallax scroll
we do not need to go inside baseball on
this but the the guys who are working on
this did an amazing job and there were
uh internal technical reasons as well
better than a parallax scroll we
simulated a parallax scroll with
animation which is even cooler so
check that out on the desktop site
indeed
um so what we are going to do over the
next
13 weeks or so um if you would just
scroll up a little bit zach
is each week we're going to do a segment
of the podcast devoted to
one of the chapters and so i'll just
read for those of you
listening and not looking the names of
the chapters and so started whenever our
next live stream
is um we will do a little excerpt from
and discuss
the human niche and then a brief history
of the human lineage which is the deep
history
of like our life on earth ancient bodies
modern world
chapter four is medicine then food then
sleep sex and gender parenthood and
relationship
childhood school becoming adults
culture and consciousness and the fourth
frontier
so some of those will be a little bit
opaque at this point but they will
become
less opaque as we talk about them and
certainly um
if you end up reading the book so
today what we're going to do is uh just
read an excerpt from the introduction
and then talk about it a little bit all
right
so this is this is actually the second
half of the introduction the first half
has a story
um of a you know nominally near-death
experience that we had in our very first
season doing field work
many years ago which i am not going to
read on air here it was one of our
earliest near-death experiences it was
one of our earliest near-death
experiences
so i'm going to read from the
introduction starting after that story
many people have attempted to explain
the cultural dissolution we face but
most have failed to provide a holistic
explanation that not only examines our
present
but also looks back into our past our
whole past and into the future
we are evolutionary biologists who have
done empirical work on sexual selection
and the evolution of sociality
and theoretical work on the evolution of
trade-offs senescence and morality
we are also married to each other have a
family together and have often been side
by side while exploring many parts of
the globe
well over a decade ago when we were
still college professors we began
formulating the idea for this book
we stood on the shoulders of giants our
mentors and senior colleagues as well as
many intellectual ancestors whom we
never met
but we're also building curriculum that
was unlike any that came before
we forged new paths and posited new
explanations for patterns both old and
new
we came to know our undergraduate
students well and as they engaged our
curricula they asked questions across
domains
what should i be eating why is dating so
difficult how do we create a more just
and free society
the common threads throughout these
conversations in classrooms and labs in
jungles and around campfires
were logic evolution and science
science is a method that oscillates
between induction and deduction
we observe patterns propose explanations
and test them to see how well they
predict
things we do not yet know we thus
generate models of the world that when
we do the scientific work correctly
achieve three things they predict more
than what came before
assume less and come to fit with one
another merging into a seamless whole
ultimately in this book and with these
models we seek a single consistent
explanation of the observable universe
that has no gaps
takes nothing on faith and rigorously
describes every pattern at every scale
this goal almost certainly cannot be
attained but there is every indication
that it can be approached
though we may glimpse this endpoint from
our modern perch where a long way from
reaching the limits of what can be known
that said we are much closer to the goal
in some areas than in others
in physics we seem tantalizingly near a
theory of everything which really means
a complete model of the least complex
most fundamental layer of explanation
and here we've endnoted your brother
eric weinstein's work
as we move up in complexity things
become less and less predictable
near the top of the stack we reach
biology where processes inside even the
simplest living cells are nowhere near
fully understood
things only get more complex from there
as cells begin to function in
coordinated ways becoming organisms made
up of distinct tissues
the degree of mystery compounds the
unpredictability jumps again in animals
governed by sophisticated neurological
feedbacks that themselves investigate
and predict the world
and once again as animals become social
and begin to pool their understanding
and divide their labor
nowhere are we more regularly stumped
than we are in understanding ourselves
we homo sapiens are brimming over with
profound mysteries surrounded by
paradoxes born of the very things that
make us distinct from the rest of the
biota
why do we laugh cry or dream why do we
mourn our dead
why do we make up stories about people
who never lived at all why do we sing
fall in love
go to war if it's all about reproduction
why do we take so many years to get on
with it
why are we so picky about with whom we
choose to do it why are we fascinated by
the reproductive behavior of others
why do we sometimes choose to impair and
disrupt our own cognition
the list of human mysteries is endless
this book will address many of those
questions it will bypass others
our primary aim here is not to simply
answer questions but to introduce you to
a robust scientific framework for
understanding ourselves
one we have developed over decades of
study and teaching on the topic
it is not a framework you will find
elsewhere we developed it by working
from first principles as much as
possible
first principles are those assumptions
that cannot be deduced from any other
assumption
they are foundational like axioms and
math and so thinking from first
principles is a power
powerful mechanism for deducing truth
and a worthy goal
if you are interested in fact over
fiction among the many benefits of first
principles thinking is that it helps one
avoid falling prey to the naturalistic
fallacy which is the idea that what is
in nature is what ought to be
the framework that we present here is
built to free us from these sorts of
traps
it is intended to allow us humans to
make sense enough of ourselves that we
can
at a minimum protect ourselves from
self-inflicted harm
in this book we will identify the most
large-scale problems of our time
not through the limiting divisive lens
of politics but through the
indiscriminate lens of our evolution
one of our hopes is that we can help you
to see through the noise of our modern
world and become a better problem solver
modern homo sapiens arose approximately
200 000 years ago
the product of 3.5 billion years of
adaptive evolution
we are in most ways a generic species
our morphology and physiology
though staggering and marvelous when
considered in isolation are not special
when compared to those of our nearest
relatives
but we uniquely have transformed the
globe and become a threat to the planet
in which we still thoroughly depend we
might have called this book a
post-industrialist's guide to the 21st
century
or an agriculturalist's guide or a
monkey's guide or a mammal's guide
or a fish's guide every one of those
represents a stage of evolutionary
history to which we have adapted and
from which we carry evolutionary baggage
our environment of evolutionary
adaptedness or eea to use the term of
art
in this book we speak to our
environments of evolutionary adaptedness
which is to say not just the eea of the
title such as the african grasslands and
woodlands and coasts on which our
ancestors were hunter-gatherers for so
long
but the many other eeas to which we are
adapted
we emerged onto land as early tetrapods
became lactating furbearing mammals
developed dexterity with our hands and
visual acuity as monkeys
grew and harvested our own food as
agriculturalists and lived cheek to jowl
with millions of anonymous others as
post-industrialists
we chose to include hunter-gatherer in
the title of the book because our recent
ancestors spent millions of years
adapting to that niche
this is the reason so many people
romanticize this particular phase of our
evolution
but there was not just one
hunter-gatherer way of life any more
than there was one mammalian way of life
or a single way to farm
and we are not adapted only to being
hunter-gatherers we also adapted long
ago to being fish
more recently to being primates and most
recently to being post-industrialists
all of these are part of our
evolutionary history
this wide-ranging view is necessary if
we are to understand the biggest problem
of our time
our species pace of change now outstrips
our ability to adapt
we are generating new problems at a new
and accelerating rate and it is making
us sick
physically psychologically socially and
environmentally
if we don't figure out how to grapple
with the problem of accelerating novelty
humanity will perish a victim of its
success
this is a book not only about how our
species is in danger
of oops sorry this is a book
not only about how our species is in
danger of destroying our world
it is also about the beauty that humans
have discovered and created and how we
can save it
an irrefutable evolutionary truth
undergirding this book is that humans
are excellent at responding to change
and adapting to the unknown
we are explorers and innovators by
design and the same impulses that have
created our troublesome modern condition
are the only hope for saving it
i'm excited i am too um
i'm very excited for this to be out in
the world and for us to be sharing
pieces of it uh as as the weeks go on is
there anything you want to add
to that part of the introduction that i
have just read from yeah i mean there
are a number of things in there that are
key many will be familiar to long-time
viewers and listeners i think the idea
you know i'm particularly fond of the
idea that the goal is a
seamless integration of models at every
level and that that cannot be achieved
and we already know it but it probably
can be approached which
is effectively the same thing that's a
really important and subtle
distinction and if people understand
that that's what you're doing it's not
that you arrogantly think that actually
a theory of everything is actually going
to allow you to go from the particle
level to predicting the next behavior of
the person in front of you
nothing of the kind but the
compatibility of all of these things
is the objective and the fact that they
are wildly incompatible at the moment
tells us what we need to figure out
right it's the incompatibility between
things
that drives proper inquiry it is
that it is a kind of perverse obsession
with the inconsistency
that turns you into a scientist right
the need to figure out how a
and b can both simultaneously be true
and they seem incompatible
as we say later in the book paradoxes
are like
an x on a treasure map right they say
dig here figure
like what what is this inconsistency
about uh
in in a scientific worldview worldview
you don't say ah let's agree to disagree
let's figure out what the source of the
disagreement is
and uh and figure out you know
who's got the perspective that isn't
actually a match for what is true
even if it is best for the majority of
people
actually to agree to disagree and wait
for somebody else to figure out what
fills in the gap you don't necessarily
want a society full of people obsessed
with the inconsistencies you might not
be able to do anything
include feed yourself if that's the uh
the construction of your civilization
but a division of labor
in which some people are obsessed by
those inconsistencies and driven to
do all of the what seems like spinning
of your wheels that is necessary in
order to finally figure out what fits in
these gaps
which is often you know you can spend
literally decades
chasing something and what you find is
some elegant little thing that takes
just a minute to describe right so you
know that is a weird
kind of investment regime right it's
like having to drill
thousands of oil wells to find one but
the one carries the necessary fluid to
fuel what you're up to and so anyway i'm
very excited
uh that what we have been doing kind of
more or less off the cuff on darkhorse
and what we did
in the classroom at uh you know very
different between you and me but a
higher level of
uh you know preparedness lectures that
had been developed over years were
deployed
upgraded each year and all of that that
that milieu now has
a kind of third place that it lives
which is this book where we've taken
um the toolkit and tried to get it into
a form
where it's sort of you can hand it off
right yeah and uh so this is um perhaps
the most
uh conscious manifestation of our
efforts to use the model that we
introduce
that we we talked about in the talk we
gave at princeton virtually
about a year ago that we introduced in
the first chapter of the book and speak
to
a lot more in the 12th chapter of the
book culture versus consciousness
yeah and i mean i must say the
experience of
building it has been totally educational
to me you wrote a book before i've never
been part of
uh book writing before and you know
that process even within an individual
article where you lose objectivity about
what you've said and so you're sort of
in a race against
time to get it out before you forget
what it even looks like
um that's compounded so much in this
circumstance because you're dealing not
only with the individual topics but
you're dealing with
you know how they fit together and what
you maybe said in a draft and then
it's not there anymore but it needs to
be in so anyway i'm
shocked and i must say almost all of the
work that went into keeping track of
what we did and didn't say and making
sure that we got it all
um sayable and clear
and you know the immense job of writing
the book is not
what i had no idea what it even was
until
we engaged in this project and that work
was almost all you i never could have
kept track of
you know a fraction of what was
necessary to get this into a form
that uh people can read it so well
here it is proofs soon to be an actual
pound even
that i just did it fedex or something
all right um
one just one more thing so we got handed
um
i i didn't actually know this because my
first book didn't have an index or maybe
it did
actually i don't know it's not in this
room um but i don't remember anything
about how my first book which is about
my research and life in madagascar when
i was in graduate school
antipode um i don't remember anything
about how the index if it exists even
uh was created so we just got handed a
draft index that was
created by someone at the publisher
yesterday
and um just began looking through it
and i admit to have a really geeky
fondness for for indexes and books it's
sometimes the thing if i'm
back in the days when browsing in
bookshops was a thing and i love doing
it and i hope to be
really comfortable and excited about
doing it again any day now
uh when you know everyone else is also
engaged in that sort of thing
um i i will often actually look to the
index first just to to see what kinds of
topics got pulled out right and so um
i think each week we'll just we'll just
sort of throw a dart
and um craziest index ever i i i love it
so
just just the first what is this like
eight things at the letter r
just what begins the letter r in the
index
we have of this hunter-gatherer's guide
to the 21st century
radial symmetry rape rapid eye movement
sleep
rat enrichment experiments ravens
raw food diets and raise
raised raised as in skates and rays as
in um as in the other half of the
um it's the chondrichthyes and the
elasmobranks or shark skates and rays
yep yeah awesome this episode of the
dark horse podcast brought to you by the
letter r
that's right that's right yeah maybe we
should have uh have our
excellent producer put together a sesame
street style uh
this this episode brought to you by uh
whatever by the letter r
and the prime number 83. that's right
that's right
yeah we're doing sesame street for
adults here
you